I bought all the PlayStation 5
controllers which would you choose the
original white dual sense was followed
up by the midnight black and Cosmic red
versions time went by and the Starlight
blue Galactic purple and this little
cheeky number known as the Nova pink
were added to the collection the next
installment saw the much adored gray
camouflage release which was
overshadowed by the God of War Ragnarok
limited edition dual sense complete with
custom paint job and after years of
begging Sony finally brought us a Pro
Controller the Dual sense Edge packed
with high level custom functions
including replaceable thumbstick modules
and funky back buttons but it cost a
crazy amount of money and that leads us
to this beauty the Hogwarts Legacy
limited edition dual sense these things
sold out so quickly I had to buy this
for a crazy price on eBay honestly I
cannot pick a favorite so that's why